et avec nous pour ce club j'admi kalimi
bonjour Janick merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Bernard Didier bonjour merci
d'être là directeur de l'Institut
Supérieur du travail expert des
questions sociales et syndicales Audrey
nous a rejoint bonjour Audrey on va
parler de la rencontre entre Elisabeth
Bornel et syndicats hier elle a tourné
court les syndicats ont demandé le
retrait de la réforme refuse la première
ministre alors est tombé désormais dans
une situation de blocage et que peuvent
faire les syndicats pestilent encore sur
la mobilisation au risque-t-il d'être
débordé par leur base peuvent-ils encore
dialoguer avec l'exécutif on verra ce
que vous en pensez on va vous entendre
dans quelques instants d'abord on
regarde l'actualité dans nos régions on
va évidemment parler de cette 11e
journée de mobilisation
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Montpellier retrouver Vincent Coste
bonjour Vincent merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous journaliste au Midi Libre
Vincent alors chez vous la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites Vincent
elle est toujours forte beaucoup de
défilés prévus aujourd'hui
beaucoup oui c'est ça qui est étonnant
là le nombre de participants dans les
dans les défilés se réévalués au fur et
à mesure de de la journée bien sûr mais
ce qui reste étonnant pour une onzième
journée de mobilisation c'est que par
exemple en
Occitanie si on prend le département de
si on prend de le département de
l'Hérault il va pas y avoir seulement
une manifestation à Montpellier et par
exemple à Béziers 7 les deux autres
villes du du département mais il y aura
neuf défilés différents neuf
manifestations distinctes dans dans le
département à Montpellier Béziers 7 bien
sûr mais aussi à Lunel à Bédarieux dans
des gros villages ou des gros Bourges ou
d'habitude leur événements de journée de
mobilisation de ce type il n'y a pas
forcément
voir très rarement dans de mobilisation
nous avons la même situation par exemple
dans le département voisin du Gard où il
y a effectivement une grande
manifestation à Nîmes une autre à Alès
mais il y en a trois autres d'organiser
sur le sur les seuls départements de
l'Hérault et du Gard c'est une quinzaine
de de défilés qui seront organisés
aujourd'hui et comme on l'a vu donc dès
le début de dès le début de ce mouvement
le le la mobilisation est forte dans les
dans les petites et moyennes villes de
provinces voir dans les voir dans les
gros villages avec des défilés
inédits de pas leur ampleur comme de par
leur existence même Vincent amo sur
votre une c'est un entretien avec
Laurent Berger
oui nous avons eu journaliste Midi Libre
à effectuer effectivement entretenu avec
avec Laurent Berger hier après-midi
Laurent Berger évidemment qui qui
maintient ses positions qui nous
expliquent que le que les changements à
la tête de la CGT par exemple ne change
rien en matière d'action et d'efficacité
de
l'interdical et qui Laurent Berger qui
qui lance quelque part un appel à
Emmanuel Macron et qui dit que oui si
Emmanuel Macron veut le rencontrer veut
rencontrer l'intersyndicale évidemment
il y aura il ira rencontré il ira
rencontré Emmanuel Macron mais en
restant sur cette sur ce positionnement
qu'elle appelle Emmanuel Macron comme on
le voit à faire preuve de sagesse ça
veut dire évidemment reculer sur la
mesure d'âge qui pivot de la de cette
réforme des retraites
pour l'instant n'accepte pas bien sûr et
on va en parler merci beaucoup Vincent
Coste d'avoir été avec nous il a eu la
une du Midi Libre c'est donc cet
entretien avec Laurent Berger l'appel à
Macron c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci Vincent 11e journée de
mobilisation alors Vincent nous le
disait toujours de la mobilisation du
côté de Montpellier et de l'Occitanie
est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
mobilisation en hausse ou est-ce qu'on
va rester un peu sur la lignée de la
précédente journée est-ce que on sent un
essoufflement finalement un moment de
creux dans cette mobilisation on sait
qu'on est en stand-by c'est le mot
couramment usité là depuis quelques
semaines lors de la dernière
mobilisation effectivement le nombre de
manifestants et le taux de grévistes
avaient avait diminué tout le monde tout
le monde c'est-à-dire exécutif
parlementaire élu et bien sûr syndicat
attendent quoi la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel voilà on est dans une
période où on continue à faire
vivre la mobilisation on le voit
évidemment c'est pas des grèves
reconductibles c'est pas des
mobilisations
permanentes mais les syndicats ne
veulent peut pas faire diminuer
l'attention donc aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il y en aura plus c'est ce qui en
aura moins sauf si les rues sont
particulièrement vides mais ça je ne le
pense pas
certes le taux de grévistes est en
diminution puisqu'on peut le prévoir en
tout cas dans les services publics mais
je pense que le gouvernement ne doit pas
trop se réjouir la tension est là la
mobilisation est là l'unité syndicale
est toujours là donc l'attention reste
forte
les prévisions de grève sont en
diminution les syndicats appellent à la
mobilisation est-ce qu'ils ont encore la
capacité de mobilisation oui la
détermination est vraiment très forte
nous sommes à la 11e journée il y a déjà
eu quatre manifestations avec plus d'un
million de manifestants chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur ça rapproché de
ce que l'on avait vécu en 2010 il y
avait eu 14 manifestations dont trois
qui avaient dépassé un million alors
évidemment en 2010 la réforme avait été
votée et les manifestations n'avaient
pas débouché sur un succès syndical mais
en 2010 il y avait eu une relation
permanente entre l'exécutif le pouvoir
politique et les organisations
syndicales et c'est fondamentalement
différent aujourd'hui on pourrait
presque dire que le Président de la
République peut aujourd'hui remercier
d'une certaine façon les organisations
syndicales parce que si les
organisations syndicales qui sont dans
les territoires qui sont dans les
professions n'occupent pas le terrain le
vide créé par leur effacement sinon leur
disparition profiteraient à qui en
politique on a la réponse et sur le plan
social on a aussi eu l'exemple en 2018
2019 avec les gilets jaunes d'une
réponse violente un face à face entre
l'exécutif et la foule
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un risque
oui un risque démocratique pour vous oui
il y a un risque démocratique en ce sens
que le Président de la République doit
être respecté dans ses prérogatives il
n'y a pas de partage du pouvoir dans une
cinquième république mais il doit y
avoir un respect des corps interviennent
et quand une crise émerge on le voit
dans une entreprise nous à l'iester on
le vit tous les jours quand une crise
émerge entre la direction et les
salariés qui doit gérer la crise
essentiellement la ligne managériale et
managers de proximité en France en
politique les managers de proximité
s'appellent les mers il y en a 35000
alors justement Emmanuel Macron
Elizabeth pardon pas du tout Emmanuel
Macron a rencontré hier l'Inter
syndicale Audrey ce qu'on peut parler
d'un rendez-vous à thé ou même d'un
dialogue de sourd choisissez vos mots
pourtant il y avait un point positif
c'est la première fois qu'Elisabeth
borne recevait les syndicats depuis
janvier dernier une tentative pour
renouer le dialogue qui a donc échoué
après moins d'une heure de réunion alors
la première ministre a d'abord voulu
parler des carrières longues de l'emploi
le seigneur de la pénibilité oui mais
voilà elle a aussi dit qu'elle refusait
de retirer la réforme l'allongement de
l'âge de départ en retraite de 62 à 64
ans c'était la condition sinequanone
pour l'interdy syndicale pour reprendre
le dialogue c'est Laurent Berger le
patron de la CFDT qui aurait mis un
terme au rendez-vous au nom de toute
l'Inter syndical un nom d'une seule voix
donc pour les 8 organisations syndicales
et ça ça a été scruté aussi parce que
vous le savez le visage de la CGT a
changé c'est Sophie Binet qui a remplacé
Philippe Martinez à la tête du syndicat
vous allez l'entendre la tête change
mais la ligne ne change pas écouté
notre présence ici elle prouve notre
sens des responsabilités et du dialogue
nous avons trouvé face à nous un
gouvernement radicalisé obtus et
déconnecté c'est une gifle au visage des
millions de Françaises et de Français
qui sont dans la rue qui sont en grève
qui sont opposés à la retraite à 64 ans
à l'allongement de la durée de
cotisations et à la suppression des
régimes spéciaux
cette stratégie
elle est violente et elle est
irresponsable alors vous le voyez les
mots sont forts de son côté Elisabeth
borne a pris brièvement la parole elle a
fait bonne figure sans esquisser pour
autant de sortie de crise écoutée
c'était un échange respectueux où chacun
a pu s'exprimer et s'écouter j'ai
entendu tour à tour chacune des
organisations syndicales
j'ai entendu leur désaccord sur le
relèvement de l'âge et j'ai pu le redire
ma conviction et celle de mon
gouvernement de la nécessité de cette de
cette réforme
on dirait qu'ils ont pas forcément
participé à la même réunion la première
ministre qui a conclu en disant qu'elle
n'envisageait pas d'avancer sans les
partenaires sociaux alors à ce stade ça
paraît quand même un peu compliqué
d'autant qu'un peu plus tard dans la
soirée Laurent Berger le patron de la
CFDT s'est exprimé sur à la télévision
il parle lui d'une grave crise
démocratique
dans un pays on n'arrive pas à se parler
après autant de de mobilisation c'est
quand même qu'on a un problème on a un
problème l'autre raison c'est que on le
voit bien ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est de créer un profond
ressentiment et le ressentiment il est à
double il est sur le contenu cette
réforme des retraites et aujourd'hui il
est un ressentiment une défiance à
l'égard des institutions on est passé
d'une crise sociale à un ressentiment
une crise démocratique le patron de la
CFDT qui ne digère pas non plus les pics
à dominem du président de la République
qui estiment que la CFDT met de l'huile
sur le feu sans rien présenter en
échange Laurent Berger qui a appelé
Emmanuel Macron hier à garder ses nerfs
vous le voyez on est loin d'un retour
autour de la table des négociations
alors il y a eu il y a eu quand même
dialogue rencontre est-ce que le lien
est désormais rompu entre les syndicats
et l'exécutifs non il ne l'est jamais
cette les deux comptes rendus côté
syndical côté Premier ministre donne le
sentiment de n'a que les participants
n'étaient pas la même réunion s'ils
étaient à la même réunion ce fut
courtois ce fut bien élevé on ne
s'invite pas simplement ce fut bref et
ferme à chaque fois les leaders
syndicaux dit madame la Première
ministre est-ce que vous retirez votre
réforme on connaissait la réponse à
l'avance donc le lien n'est pas rompu et
c'est important vous savez le monde
syndical c'est pas uniquement Sophie
biner Laurent Berger c'est aussi la FSU
Sud autour de la CGT et puis autour la
CFDT vous avez la FTC la CFE-CGC l'INSA
Force Ouvrière aussi qui compte dans
dans cette affaire là donc c'est c'est
un tissu d'organisation syndicale qui
répétons le sont en contact avec les
professions et les territoires un
chiffre la CGT compte aujourd'hui sur le
territoire français 803 union locale
alors on pourrait dire la CGT n'a pas au
moment des des gilets jaunes
occupaient les ronds-points qu'on fait
les 803 union locale c'est vrai mais les
organisations syndicales font partie
comme les partis politiques s'ils
étaient en meilleure forme de ces corps
intermédiaires qui aident la démocratie
respirer
est-ce que la réunion d'hier a été utile
pour vous génériques effectivement il y
avait quand même peu doute sur son
issu mais est-ce qu'elle a eu une
utilité est-ce qu'on était dans une
posture des deux côtés on était dans une
posture mais comme le disait Bernard
Vivier et puis comme le disent
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
qui étaient présentes et qui se sont
déplacés tout le monde savait que chacun
resterait sur ses positions encore une
fois pourquoi parce que il y a le
Conseil constitutionnel et je ne veux
même pas parler de la proposition de loi
référendaire qui est elle aussi
pendantes mais pour répondre à votre
question oui elle était utile oui elle
était nécessaire oui elle était
indispensable aussi bien pour l'exécutif
que pour les organisations syndicales
quelles qu'elles soient plus ou moins
réformatrice ou plus ou moins radicale
elle était nécessaire parce qu'il faut
garder le contact et montrer qu'on garde
le contact parce qu'on dit souvent on le
répète les contacts étaient dans la
coulisse mais il est bien aussi de
montrer que contact à un dialogue pour
le moment il y a entre l'exécutif et les
organisations syndicales ça c'est une
chose extrêmement importante dans notre
démocratie aussi grippée soit-elle moi
je ne parlerai pas de crise démocratique
Chris politique peut-être certainement
pas crise démocratique dans un pays où
toutes les oppositions peuvent quand
même s'exprimer même si le gouvernement
ne prend pas en compte toutes les
revendications il en a pris quand même
en compte quelques-unes bref je ferme
cette parenthèse mais continuer à être
voté au Parlement en plus en plus mais
même sur la retraite on peut pas dire
enfin certes le gouvernement reste droit
dans ses bottes sur les 62 64 ans on est
bien d'accord il a pris quand même en
compte beaucoup d'autres propositions
qu'elles viennent des LR qu'elle vienne
de cette d'autres partis politiques ou
des syndicats donc la réunion d'hier oui
était importante je pense que le
gouvernement a intérêt à faire vivre
comme vous le disiez Bernard vivier
cette démocratie sociale dans les mois
qui viennent d'autant plus qu'il n'est
sûr de rien à l'Assemblée nationale
d'une part et d'autre part que le le les
organisations syndicales aussi ont tout
à fait intérêt à le faire mais moi je
pense pour terminer que ce sont les
organisations syndicales qui ont la main
dans les le dialogues et dans les
négociations qui vont s'ouvrir parce que
encore une fois si
Elisabeth borne ou le gouvernement
quelle que soit son chef dans les mois
qui viennent arrivent à sortir de la
crise il ne l'aura pas résolu et comme
dit Laurent Berger d'autres la colère
est toujours présente et que il y a
les syndicats
de la colère mais juste je fais réagir à
Bernard vivier sur Bernard vivier pardon
sur ce que vous venez de dire est-ce que
ce sont les syndicats qui ont la main et
comment on peut faire vivre la
démocratie sociale dans les prochaines
semaines avec Elisabeth borne qui veut
aller de l'avant parler de la suite et
des cas qui disent mais on veut pas
parler de la suite tant qu'il y a cette
réforme oui les deux volets de votre
question renvoient à une question
centrale qui dans le pays doit organiser
la vie sociale le pouvoir exécutif bien
évidemment le politique est en surplomb
de tout ce qui se passe dans le pays
mais il existe des sphères de la vie
sociale qui appart qui n'appartiennent
pas par nature au pouvoir politique le
patronat et les syndicats ont pour
nature pour vocation d'organiser le
marché du travail si on veut parler de
pénibilité de carrière longue d'emploi
des seniors d'égalité hommes femmes
quantité de sujets qu'est-ce qu'un
ministre du Travail ou un ministre la
fonction publique peut faire sur le
sujet mission de la fonction publique
oui parce que ce sont ces employés ces
salariés enfin ces fonctionnaires plus
exactement il y en a 5 millions 600 000
mais dans tous les secteur privé ce sont
les organisations syndicales et
patronales qui doivent le faire syndicat
et patronats ont élaboré de façon très
discrète
malheureusement un agent d'associal
autonome c'est-à-dire une sphère de
négociation
dans laquelle ils peuvent décider mais à
condition évidemment que le gouvernement
ne préonte pas le sujet or il existe
dans le code du travail un article qui
l'article 1 qui avait été installé par
Gérard Larcher quand il est ministre du
Travail et qui dit en substance quand
les partenaires sociaux veulent débat 32
d'un sujet entre eux d'un sujet ils en
parlent à la puissance publique et ils
disent écoutez pendant que l'on discute
ne soyez pas au dessus de nous pour dire
quand il faut finir et ce qu'il faut
mettre dans la conclusion la question
maintenant est Janique vous en parler
c'est la mobilisation certes elle
continue mais va-t-elle s’étendre à
d'autres sujets et agréger certaines
colères Marion Delpech est allé dans la
Somme rencontrée les salariés du site
d'Amazon à beau ils sont en colère et
bloquent les entrées du site un
mouvement qui fait suite à l'appel de
l'Inter syndical pour dénoncer la
réforme des retraites mais aussi pour
réclamer des hausses de salaire
au loin l'immense plateforme logistique
d'Amazon près d'Amiens aucun colis n'en
sortira ce mardi matin car les salariés
bloquent depuis 6 heures deux entrées du
site logistique déterminés à montrer
leur colère face à ce qu'il considère
comme un passage en force du
gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites mais aussi pour tenter une
nouvelle fois de se faire entendre sur
leur revendications salariale on puisse
s'en sortir tous les mois parce que en
début de mois tout le monde ou en milieu
de mois les salariés sont dans la dans
la crise on va dire et moi le premier et
ce qu'on veut c'est une augmentation
générale conséquente suite à la station
en tout cas on est maman solo avec des
enfants on est à peu près allé on va
dire à 1500 euros par mois en payant
l'essence moi je sais que je fais 60 km
aller-retour par jour et du coup je
remplis souvent le réservoir quoi et
c'est vraiment ce qui impacte le plus le
budget des salariés soutenus par
l'intersyndicale départementale à
l'origine de la décision du blocage le
but toucher à l'économie des grands
groupes et faire plier le gouvernement
sur la réforme des retraites et la
mobilisation est loin de s'essouffler
selon eux vous avez une opérationnel
vous avez une reconduction de la grève
qui se poursuit chez EDF qui se poursuit
chez les cheminots et vous avez un
mandat de la CGT qui est très clair
c'est il y aura pas de médiation il y
aura pas de traîne on continue jusqu'au
retrait
déjà on a vu la semaine dernière la
manifestation qui a réuni beaucoup plus
de monde que la première déjà donc au
niveau essoufflement n'y est pas on est
plutôt quand même dans une dans une
action en fait où les salariés nous
soutiennent une détermination qui semble
contagieuse et qui s'intensifie même ici
sur ce piquet de grève ou les étudiants
sont venus soutenir les travailleurs de
syndicats lunaires et la FSE ont fait le
déplacement bien que le gouvernement
utilise tous les mécanismes possibles
pour stopper la manifester la
mobilisation que ce soit la répression
de plus en plus forte des manifestants
ou que ce soit les décisions
autoritaires pour passer la réforme en
force les étudiants de continuer à se
mobiliser c'est super on n'a pas des
soufflement en tout cas on constate pas
et c'est génial pour tous ceux présents
ce jour-là il n'y a pas de doute la
détermination est intacte et si des
divergences se font ressentir entre
certaines forces syndicales au niveau
national il l'assure ici
l'intersyndical restera soudée cette
réforme de retraite nous on a une ligne
rouge à la CFDT que même notre chef
monsieur berger ne pourra pas dépasser
ça a été décidé en congrès et on ne
passera pas ses 62 ans donc il est pas
question qu'on aille à 64 ans donc on a
peut-être des distorsions peut-être avec
d'autres syndicats mais en tout cas nous
ici dans la Somme on tient à cette
interditale parce que ça fonctionne
depuis très longtemps déjà et on tient
la garder une nouvelle mobilisation est
prévue dès demain dans toute la France
et à Amiens ainsi que d'autres blocages
dans les jours à venir
qu'est-ce qu'on est dans un mouvement on
le voit là avec l'exemple de ces
salariés qui va changer de forme une
extension de la colère une agrégation
des différentes revendications écoutez
on sait que depuis la réforme des
retraites et la mobilisation depuis le
mois de janvier au mois de février que
soit les syndicats ou les partis
politiques notamment la France insoumise
à chercher à aboutir et à déclencher
cette coalition des colères dont vous
parliez ces colères existent pour les
salariés notamment les plus modestes on
le voit ça se coagule avec l'inflation
et le problème de la hausse des prix et
des salaires qui ne sont pas indexés sur
la hausse des prix et pour les étudiants
on a vu après un début difficile que les
jeunes et notamment les étudiants
commencent également à se mettre en
branle à se mettre en mouvement à partir
du 49-3 parce qu'au-delà de la réforme
des retraites qui les concernait peu ça
a été plutôt la critique et l'opposition
politique au sens large du terme et de
d'une réforme des institutions qu'ils
appelaient de leurs vœux de là à dire à
l'heure qu'il est que il va avoir une
coalition des colères et que du coup les
cortèges vont grossir et les grèves
voire les les les les carrefours comme
au temps des gilets jaunes vont se
multiplier personnellement moi je ne le
pense pas il risque tout de même encore
une fois attendons la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel d'avoir une
sorte d'essoufflement du mouvement mais
pas d'affaiblissement je pense encore
une fois que les colères sont totales
que l'unité syndicale
rester au moins dans les propos à
l'opposition ou du gouvernement ou de la
réforme des retraites et que il va avoir
encore une fois une France et un
exécutif sous pression de là à ce qu'on
aille un grand soir avec une coalition
des colères alors qu'il est je ne le
pense pas du tout
les forces politiques sont divisées
éclatées atomisées en tout cas celle qui
sont dans la logique de gouvernement
c'est un vrai désastre un bombardement
et à l'Assemblée nationale les forces
syndicales sont établies structurées
mais les forces syndicales répétons le
ne sont pas aujourd'hui au centre de la
ne sont pas en capacité centrale pour
tenir toutes les colères alors nous
avons parce qu'on entendait c'est un peu
une forme d'avertissement lancé par ces
salariés dans le sujet est-ce que ça
veut dire que les leaders syndicaux
risquent d'être débordés par leur base
oui et non les organisations syndicales
sont des structures des appareils si on
peut dire bien bien organisé le leader
de la CFDT qui vient de s'exprimer dans
sa région dit Laurent Berger il fait ce
qu'il veut mais nous non on sera dans
l'unité syndicale on se calme après
l'esprit famille CFDT va l'emporter mais
il est à l'écoute de préoccupations qui
sont des préoccupations qui ont
largement ça vient d'être dit dépassé
à dépasser le dossier des retraites sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat dans leur
portage l'indique une jeune femme qui
dit moi j'ai 1500 euros je me fais 60 km
par jour les sens ça coûte et nous
retrouvons là les ingrédients d'une
colère lourde par-delà les organisations
syndicales c'est l'accès aux soins la
capacité à se déplacer à se transporter
c'est l'accès au service public ça a
l'air tout ce qui a permis
malheureusement en 2018 de voir le
phénomène des gilets jaunes et là les
organisations syndicales comme les
partis politiques étaient débordés vous
savez il y a aujourd'hui le son moins
ils le sont toujours non les syndicats
sont là pas les partis politiques hier
j'étais à Saint-Nazaire et la personne
qui m'accueille me dit vous savez le
maire de Saint-Brévin a vu sa poubelle
brûlée et la poubelle a mis le feu à la
maison donc on en parle peu mais nous
avons toujours une violence latente et
ça me Brévin c'est pas une commune par
nature violente voilà et est-ce que ça
veut dire que du coup le mouvement
politique n'incarne pas n'est pas le
relais du mouvement syndical notamment
au Parlement alors attention
les partis politiques n'ont pas pour
vocation d'être ni les relais des
syndicats ni les donneurs d'ordre des
organisations syndicales nous avons en
France toujours le sentiment que parti
politique de gauche est syndicat c'est
tout un mouvement ouvrier c'est faux
dans d'autres pays européens il y a des
relations très étroites entre les partis
politiques et les syndicats notamment
les partis politiques de gauche et les
syndicats mais chacun dans son rôle
Frédéric Souillot secrétaire général de
Force Ouvrière le dit toujours très bien
nous avons depuis le mois de janvier
organisé des manifestations c'est ce
sont des manifestations inter syndicales
les parties dit-il en substance c'est
sur les côtés derrière mais pas dans le
carré de tête
écoutez
le
les forces politiques et l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat et le Parlement
peuvent avoir un rôle à jouer dans le
contexte actuel à condition que
l'exécutif arrive à capter ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui comme nous le disions
la situation est bloquée
ça paraît évident mais comme vous le
disiez Bernard vivier les syndicats
peuvent donner une occasion à Emmanuel
Macron et au Premier ministre qu'il Ken
ou quel qu'il soit ou quelle qu'elle
soit de donner un nouveau souffle ou un
premier souffle j'en sais rien à ce
nouveau quinquennat qui manque
véritablement et apparemment et
évidemment d'inspiration comment en
ouvrant des grandes négociations
oublions
il faut de toute façon négociation
sociale s'ouvrent c'est négociations
avec l'État pour le coup donnant du
grain à moudre à la représentation
nationale que sont l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat et même s'il n'y a pas de
majorité sur pour l'exécutive à
l'Assemblée nationale je ne vois pas
comment les députés quel que soit leur
configurations pourraient refuser un
grand accord sur des conditions de
travail sur la pénibilité ou sur autre
chose s'il a été validé par les
organisations syndicales donc je pense
que là on est à une nouvelle un nouvel
comment dire nouvelle configuration du
pouvoir politique du pouvoir législatif
et du pouvoir social il faut que
l'exécutif fasse en sorte que la
mayonnaise prenne et qu'il arrive à
faire sortir la France non pas lui-même
mais la France par le haut et une
dernière question pour terminer parce
que Janique vous en parliez tout à
l'heure et on l'a entendu dans le
reportage il y a des questions qui se
posent autour de l'unité syndicale alors
hier l'Inter syndicale s'est affiché
unie il y a notamment des questions qui
se sont posées après sélection à la tête
de la CGT de Sophie Binet le Congrès a
été très dur assez tendu Sophie Binet
hier elle a dit mais non l'unité
syndicale elle n'est pas remise en cause
contrairement à ce qu'on entend il y a
pas de fissure ça peut tenir longtemps
oui ça peut tenir longtemps parce que le
congrès de la CGT a pendant 4 jours sur
5 vécu une
psychodrame bien et la sortie de crise
s'est faite par le haut Sophie Binet est
une personne très structurée qui a déjà
été au bureau confédéral de la CGT entre
2013 et 2015 elle est très solide très
formée une très bonne dialecticienne ce
sera d'une certaine façon Philippe
Martinez bis c'est la même ligne c'est
la même ligne que le style évidemment
sera très différent elle a la volonté de
rassembler de recoudre les morceaux
déchirés en interne mais la ligne sera
celle de l'intransigeance et et le mot
lutte de classe et pour elle une
expression assez facile dans dans sa
pensée dans sa bouche
donc ça veut dire que ça va être plus
compliqué avec la CGT ou pas
avec Philipp c'était pas simple avec
Philippe Martinez et de toute façon il
vaut mieux avoir en face de soi
d'interlocuteur structuré qu'une absence
d'interlocuteur dans les entreprises
vous avez les DRH ils disent souvent moi
je préfère avoir un délégué syndical CGT
dure en affaires mais qui tient la route
et les troupes que d'avoir quelqu'un qui
fiche le camp et dont on sait pas d'où
il vient et où il va moi je pense le
problème c'est pas la CGT pour le
gouvernement très rapidement c'est le
fait comme vous le disiez que l'unité
syndicale notamment entre les deux
grands syndicales les deux grandes
confédérations se poursuivre on va
continuer à parler de ce sujet puisque
c'est à la ligne de nos quotidiens
régionaux Audrey
[Musique]
et en une de nos quotidiens on voudrait
l'échec de cette réunion hier entre
Elisabeth borne elle interditale oui ça
a marqué les quotidiens régionaux
regardez dialogue de source titre Le
Dauphiné Libéré et la montagne avec
cette photo de Laurent Berger le patron
de la CFDT et de Sophie Binet la
nouvelle chef de la CGT un peu dépité
pour la Provence c'est l'impasse l'issue
certes été prévisible on en a parlé mais
tous nos quotidiens reviennent sur ce
rendez-vous manqué entre l'Inter
syndical qui demande le retrait de la
réforme et le gouvernement inflexible
tous les regards sont donc tournés sur
la 11e journée de mobilisation dans ce
contexte l'Union s'intéresse au retour
en grâce des syndicats le front unique
ils affichent contre la réforme des
retraites redonne une assise souligne le
quotidien et ça se voit sur le terrain
dans l'Aisne par exemple les additions à
la CFDT ont augmenté ces derniers mois
entre + 7 et + 13 %. l'actualité c'est
aussi l'inflation pour s'en sortir face
à la hausse des prix de nombreux
charentais font la course aux bonnes
astuces et nous les livres dans la
Charente Libre ce matin il y a ceux qui
privilégie les dates courtes en général
c'est 30% moins faire l'autre option ce
sont les légumes mal calibrés ou ceux
qui ont eu des problèmes de livraison
c'est le cœur de métier de l'enseigne
nos gaz elle est passée de 2500 clients
par mois à 4000 Oriane on termine par
une autre plus légère ou nous parler de
foot la victoire de Nantes hier de notre
légère les Canaries qui sont en finale
de la Coupe de France après une victoire
1-0 face à Lyon grâce à un but de
Ludovic bla et puis en cette veille de
pas coréenne je vous emmène chez vous en
Corse où l'on ne prend pas les choses à
la légère pour la veille de Pâques avec
la veille de Catena
locale de l'étape ça se passe à Calvi ce
sont des processions ou des pénitents
expient leurs fautes en portant la
lourde croix du Christ en général pieds
nus sur des pavés pendant deux heures
trente ils sont cagoulés pour garder
leur anonymat traditionnellement on
était pénitent pour expliquer une faute
grave désormais ce sont des fidèles qui
veulent être au plus près de leur foi et
sachez qu'il y a des femmes qui le font
les détails sont à lire dans Corse-Matin
exactement et on invite du coup tout le
monde à lire Corse-Matin merci beaucoup
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour cette
revue de presse merci beaucoup Janick
Halimi merci Bernard vivier d'être venu
voir et on suivra bien évidemment
l'issue de cette journée de mobilisation
ce sera à suivre demain dans cette
émission demain ou vous retrouverez
Steve Jourdain à ma place et puis
prochain rendez-vous sur notre antenne
c'est à 18h Thomas Hugues sens public je
vous souhaite une très très bonne
journée et moi je vous retrouve mardi
[Musique]